[Music]
on this saturday night two shots to
travel
the new rules for trains and planes in
canada this will help us rebuild
consumer confidence plus the transition
period if you're not fully vaccinated
vaccine equity on the table we have made
a number of of
different and specific commitments what
will it take to protect poorer nations
climate targets why international travel
is exempt in the goal to reduce
emissions and stock up on stocking
stuffers because gifts may be in short
supply for christmas
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us if you have travel plans there is one
more thing to add to your packing list
proof of vaccination as of today only
fully vaccinated passengers will be
allowed to board most planes and some
trains in this country while there is a
bit of a grace period most travelers are
welcoming the move david aiken has our
top story tonight
hi there do you guys have your proof of
vaccination
it's the dawn of a new era of travel in
canada no boarding of via train the
rocky mountaineer or a plane without
showing proof of vaccination i'm from
america and we actually don't have to
prove that we have a vaccine and i
really don't like that very much i don't
feel too safe about it i support it i
live in the uk
um where there are much higher rates of
covid so anything we can do to keep each
other safe happy with that it will help
mitigate all the
risks related to carbon the rules are
pretty straight ahead they apply to any
passenger age 12 years and 4 months or
older and they apply to all employees in
the federally regulated air rail and
marine transportation sectors that
includes those working in airports train
stations and on maintenance crews as of
saturday everyone has to provide a proof
of vaccination there is a transition
period for this rule though if a
traveler or employee is not fully
vaccinated they can provide proof of a
clean pcr test taken within 72 hours of
travel no rapid antigen tests are
allowed
but as of november the 30th that
transition period is over only the fully
vaccinated can travel on planes and via
rail the testing option will be over and
there will be very few exceptions we
know today that vaccination is one of
the most effective ways to reduce the
further spread of covet 19. i think
what's really important is that this
will help us rebuild consumer confidence
uh travel our confidence and and get
people traveling again and so
if this is what it takes then you know
let's do it plane travelers will be
asked to show proof of vaccine as they
arrive at security screening areas train
travelers will be asked to show their
proof on the platform just before
boarding travelers are also encouraged
to use the new standardized canada-wide
proof of vaccination that proof is being
issued or will be issued by provincial
health authorities it comes in a paper
form but many provinces will let you
download the qr code a vaccine
certificate right on your smartphone for
easy reference at check-in robin david
deakin in ottawa thanks david
prime minister justin trudeau is in rome
for the g20 summit where there is a call
for countries to spread the wealth when
it comes to coven 19 vaccines in canada
74 of the population is fully vaccinated
and boosters are being offered in some
areas compare that to the entire
continent of africa where less than 6
percent are fully vaccinated today
canada stepped up with a big donation
but it may not be enough michael couture
is in rome tonight
prime minister justin trudeau arrived at
the g20 summit in rome looking to be a
leader in tackling climate change and
covid 19 vaccine equity
that issue was front and center of the
opening leaders session and there are
startling disparities in the global
distribution of vaccines
g20 chair and italian prime minister
mario draghi says in high-income
countries more than 70 percent of the
population has at least one dose of a
covet-19 vaccine but in the poorest
nations that rate drops to just 3
percent hoping to correct that imbalance
canada announced it's increasing its
commitment of covid19 vaccines to lower
income countries the 200 million dose
commitment which includes as i said
announced today
10 million doses directly from moderna
that will come
soon
the pledge is to use the kovac system
and bilateral agreements to get the 200
million doses delivered to low and
middle-income countries by the end of
2022
some have suggested richer countries
should forego booster shots until
developing nations are fully vaccinated
but some of our allies aren't on board i
do not agree with that
thesis what i do agree with is that we
have to make sure through the covax
programs and the other initiatives that
enough vaccines reach the parts of the
world
which have difficulty to get to access
to vaccines canada is also donating 15
million dollars to help south africa
make vaccines domestically a move
applauded by oxfam but they'd prefer
canada and other countries temporarily
waive intellectual property rights at
the world trade organization known as
trips a move that would allow vaccine
recipes to be shared with smaller
countries so they can manufacture them
more cheaply why not make that decision
on the trips rather than donate the 15
million dollars to south africa
well i think we can walk and chew gum at
the same time they'll really have most
bang for their buck if they also support
the waiver on intellectual property
rights at the world trade organization
and step up pressure on
pharmaceutical companies to share their
vaccine technology and know-how now of
the 200 million doses pledged by canada
just 3.4 million have actually been
delivered to the countries that need
them however sources tell global news
significant shipments are expected to
land in the coming days
robin michael couture in rome tonight
thanks mike
the world will be watching glasgow this
week where global leaders including the
prime minister are meeting to make new
climate commitments at the united
nations cop 26 but back in canada the
premiers of oil-producing provinces are
wary of the newly appointed environment
minister citing his past as an activist
eric sorenson is hosting this week's
edition of the west block and speaks
with intergovernmental affairs minister
dominic leblanc about navigating these
relationships eric
robin as canada's prime minister arrives
at the un climate summit he will have a
new and different environment ministered
to demonstrate this country's commitment
to meeting its targets to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions
stephen guilbell is a former
environmental activist with greenpeace
he once scaled toronto's cn tower to
hang a banner to combat pollution on
globals the west block ottawa's
intergovernmental affairs minister says
gebo's background will add to canada's
credibility in tackling canada's
emissions they'll also see somebody who
understands that the long-term
sustainable economic growth of the
country
also is married to our successful uh
fight against climate change but in
alberta there is trepidation that gilboa
will have little concern for the impact
on the oil and gas sector his own
personal background and track record on
these issues
suggests somebody who is
more of an absolutist
than a pragmatist when it comes to
finding solutions
so i i hope
i hope that i'm wrong about that alberta
will not only have guibald to deal with
but the new natural resources minister
normally the post that advocates for
industry is now the job of the former
environment minister jonathan wilkinson
ottawa's determination on climate policy
seems clear
we think that canadians in every part of
the country including in alberta want
the government to take concerted
effective action ambitious action
in the fight against climate change but
at the same time recognize that that
very work is essential to ensuring
long-term sustainable jobs not only in
the resource sectors but right across
the country dominic leblanc says he has
a constructive relationship with
alberta's premier but it will be tested
as canada prepares for the u.n climate
summit in glasgow promising that it will
meet its climate change targets eric
sorensen global news ottawa
and eric is guest hosting for mercedes
stevenson tomorrow you can catch his
full interview with dominic leblanc on
the west block right here on global
most world leaders are flying to glasgow
for cop26 global aviation accounts for
about 2.5
of the human contribution to carbon
dioxide emissions those emissions
created by the international air travel
industry will not fall under any
agreements reached at the summit to
drastically reduce the amount of co2
redmond shannon explains why and how
airlines may not need to take any action
for years to come
international flights make up the
majority of commercial aircraft
emissions but they will not be on the
table at the cop 26 summit neither will
international shipping nor military
activities
the emissions actually
fall in international airspace or
international waters
and there's been a lot of controversy
about you know how you would allocate
those emissions to individual countries
the un's civil aviation agency icao is
instead coordinating a climate change
scheme for international flights
starting this year airlines in the 88
participating countries including canada
are encouraged to make operational
efficiencies fly greener planes or use
biofuels the idea is to prevent
emissions from growing above 2019 levels
however because of the pandemic it could
be years before airlines even get back
to 2019 emission levels the 2019
baseline is in the order but of about a
gigaton of carbon dioxide and so that's
a tremendous amount of carbon dioxide if
that's that's what we're trying to get
down to and so if you have a sector it's
not trying to reduce emissions it's
trying to reduce growing emissions
and that's the real kicker if the offset
measures are not enough airlines will
need to buy carbon credits such as tree
planting schemes the effects of which
remain a challenge to accurately verify
if you really want it to account for an
offset you have to keep that carbon
dioxide out of the atmosphere
for
thousands of years literally under the
scheme known as corsia airlines only
need to offset carbon growth even though
aircraft have additional greenhouse
effects
what i hope we see is we double back and
we make sure that we're taking care of
the contrails and the nitrogen oxide as
well small private jet operators could
be exempt too so in the absence of
stronger policies and with truly carbon
neutral air travel still a long way off
climate change activists insist the real
power to reduce emissions lies very much
with the individual by choosing to fly
less redmond shannon global news london
a phenomenon known as a king tide
brought on by climate change is wreaking
havoc on the u.s east coast the powerful
storm is producing record-breaking rain
and heavy winds as jennifer johnson
reports these extreme weather events are
becoming the new norm
streets in downtown philadelphia turned
into rivers some drivers had to retreat
to the roofs of their cars as flood
waters quickly rose the slow-moving
storm brought intense downpours for
several hours from virginia to new
jersey
heavy winds too up to 80 kilometer per
hour gusts
yeah i mean it's pretty crazy
kayakers paddled through flooded streets
in downtown annapolis as maryland's
governor declared a state of emergency
meteorologists say the flooding was
caused by astronomically high so-called
king tides brought on by human-induced
climate change unfortunately this is
becoming all too normal see the water
lines and businesses every now and then
but they're used to it it's just you
know they're like yeah we're used to it
we do this we move on and we clean it up
and start all over again can we get more
than five business owners in parts of
virginia put out sandbags to protect
their goods too the ground became so wet
huge trees in the u.s capital came
tumbling down some restaurants opened
friday then had to quickly shut down
somebody was telling me they were out at
pirates cove restaurant and they had to
close the water was coming up as they
were sitting on the dock eating
the potomac river rose so high this man
was actually fishing along the george
washington parkway flooding in some
areas reached record-breaking levels
leaving d.c meteorologist bill karins to
tweet wild that this no-name storm will
likely break the all-time highest water
level ever recorded on the delaware bay
experts say coastal cities and towns are
seeing more and more major flooding from
meager storm systems another costly and
dangerous result of climate change
jennifer johnson global news washington
manitoba's progressive conservative
party has chosen its new leader and the
provinces next premier and for the first
time there will be a woman running the
province
well hello manitoba
welcome to the new pc party of manitoba
former health minister heather
stephenson was victorious in today's
leadership vote she beat out another
woman former mp shelly glover by fewer
than 400 votes the leadership race was
called after brian pallaster stepped
aside in the summer the next provincial
election is slated for october 2023
coming up on global national a rare find
in mexico dating back almost a thousand
years
[Music]
spain's military has been deployed to la
palma island where the kumbrevia volcano
has been spewing red-hot lava along with
smoke and piles of ash for nearly six
weeks the rivers of lava have destroyed
more than 2 000 buildings and forced
about 7 500 people to flee the island
in sudan protests against a military
takeover have turned deadly
[Applause]
sudan central doctors committee reports
three people were killed and dozens more
injured when security forces fired on
crowds demonstrating in a city near the
capital khartoum it's believed hundreds
of thousands of protesters took part in
the anti-coup rallies the military
seized power on wednesday detaining the
prime minister and members of the
country's transitional government
in neighboring ethiopia rebel fighters
claim to have captured control of a
strategic city armed forces from the
tigray region say they have entered the
city of desi but ethiopia's government
denies its military has been pushed out
the conflict in the country's north
erupted nearly a year ago when
ethiopia's prime minister abi ahmed
launched an offensive against the tigray
people's liberation front both sides
have been accused of killing civilians
and carrying out atrocities more than
1.7 million people have been displaced
by the fighting
archaeologists have discovered a mine
boat in southern mexico believed to be
more than a thousand years old the
five-foot wooden canoe was found almost
completely intact submerged in a
freshwater pool in chichen itza which
was once a major city of carved temples
and towering pyramids
the rare find was uncovered during
construction work on a new railway in
the city
still ahead the solar super storm the
once in a century event that could wipe
out the internet
you're watching global national
a colorful light show is expected to
decorate the skies across canada this
halloween weekend a powerful solar flare
erupted from the sun on thursday it's
set to reach earth today potentially
supercharging the aurora borealis or
northern lights
solar storms are an explosion of
energized particles hurled from the sun
and small-scale storms happen regularly
but every century or so there is an
extreme eruption new research suggests
our planet is on a crash course with one
of these super storms and as laura
casella is here to tell us canada is in
its direct path
thanks robin there's talk of how we may
be overdue for what they call a 1 in 100
solar storm one so big it could knock
out power grids damaged satellites and
cause internet blackouts essentially
taking down our modern way of life and
scientists are telling us that canada is
more at risk than other parts of the
world
that's because our country is closer to
the north pole and charged particles
from solar flares are pulled in by the
earth's magnetic field and drawn towards
the poles and canadians should hold on
tight because the planet is entering a
busy season for solar storms according
to research scientist robin fiore high
solar activity occurs on an 11-year
cycle and we just got out of a low
period so we're ramping up from a period
of very low activity where we didn't see
a lot of flares to a point where we're
starting to see more and more activity
and we're starting to expect the
potential for more impacts a major solar
storm has happened before in 1859 a
massive solar flare from the sun caused
telegraph communication to fail around
the world it was so powerful that it set
telegraph lines on fire impacts were
quite wide ranging to operators being
severely shocked or maybe having some
temporary paralysis in their fingers
to the system not really working
properly
now major utility companies are
preparing for the big one in case there
are sudden electrical surges caused by
storms we'll have more on the measures
engineers are taking to keep lights on
and the power grids running on the new
reality tonight at 7 pm robin all right
thanks for that laura
up next you better watch out supply
chain issues could spoil holiday
shopping this year
[Music]
it wouldn't be halloween without
monsters there were some pretty
frightening outfits for the annual
festival at germany's frankenstein
castle and it should come as no surprise
costumes from the popular netflix show
squid game are among the top trends this
year but an edmonton woman captured a
global feeling of 2021 by dressing up as
the ever given container ship this
version is more appropriately named ever
stuck you may remember the ship blocked
the suez canal for a week in march which
had an impact on global shipping for
months
while the supply issue may affect your
christmas plans analysts say don't get
stuck and suggest shopping early to
avoid disappointment and gaviola
continues our special coverage and digs
into supply chain issues for the holiday
season
jill roshan owns an independent toy
store in toronto if she could waive her
magic wand she'd make headaches related
to this year's holiday season disappear
it's been very difficult fortunately
distributors have
made us aware of this problem for the
last year
and so we've been getting a lot of
emails through the summer saying there
will not be christmas stock order now
she says big box stores have the upper
hand if we don't have a certain product
people are going to the big business
right away because they can get their
product probably easier supply chain
snarls haven't impacted all toys not yet
but anything coming from outside the
country is vulnerable roshan says toy
trains barns and some types of paint
have been impossible to get a hold of to
explain what's happening let's take you
on a hypothetical journey with a toy
there's a delay in manufacturing because
of rolling blackouts impacting factories
in china and there's a resin shortage a
key component for making plastic toys
once it's ready to go there's a long
queue for a shipping container to take
it overseas because shipping containers
are in short supply too plus there's a
shortage of workers to load and unload
the ships when it arrives on north
american shores there's a shortage of
truck drivers available to haul it to a
distribution center before it finally
arrives at its final destination a store
shelf
the ripple effect impacts more than just
toys the microchip and semiconductor
shortage could affect delivery of the
latest and greatest tech gadgets ebay
canada says it's already seen an
increase in buyers looking for hard to
find items it's expecting that to
accelerate with holiday shopping i've
got four boys they're not each getting
new iphones
but i can buy certified refurbished
on ebay imports like decorations and
artificial christmas trees could be
delayed in short supply and more
expensive creating an opportunity for
homegrown real trees the nice thing is
we've got acres and acres of christmas
trees all across canada with demand
expected to be strong this year like it
was in 2020 be ready to roll with the
punches come out of your comfort zone
and try something if you can't get the
tree that you're used to the advice this
year is shop early be flexible by second
hand pare down your list and if there's
an item that you have your heart set on
but it's not going to arrive in time
maybe consider repurposing it as a
valentine's day gift ann gaviola global
news toronto
already talking about valentine's day
that is global national for this
saturday night i'm robin gill tonight we
leave you with a look at the
drive-through halloween light festival
in richmond hill ontario the night of
lights is made from more than 1.5
million lights and stretches over two
kilometers thank you for watching and
we'll see you back here tomorrow have a
great night
[Music]
you